my name is Jason spires and it's age of
19 I made a stupid decision to sell
cannabis and of the prison fortunately
my mother sent me Khan Academy
transcripts to start improving my
education and while I was doing that
other inmates noticed and would come up
to me and ask what I could help them
when I asked them why don't you try to
get in the GED classes some the waiting
list was too long others I realized what
it is is it's hard to admit you don't
know something and it's embarrassing
when you're a full grown man to say that
you don't know that there's three
different ways to spell the word there
so I'd help them and when I got out I
used Khan Academy's SAT program to
prepare myself and I ended up getting a
1440 on the SATs and after that I
applied and was accepted in the Stanford
University I'm making this video today
because I want to tell you that when you
support Khan Academy you're not only
supporting people like me and helping me
get to places like Stanford you're
supporting a mission that strips away
the embarrassment factor of having to
admit you don't know something because
you want to learn something the best
teacher can only help the student if
they don't walk into the classroom and
what Khan Academy does is they put a
classroom and everybody's home on their
time on their schedule without any
embarrassment so I hope you will
continue to support Khan Academy's
mission in order to continue to support
the mission of increasing a world-class
education for everybody everywhere